Elon Musk has chimed in responding to
Alx posting this saying there does seem
to be far higher interest in pursuing
Trump compared to other people in
politics very important the justice
justice system rebut what appears to be
differential enforcement or they will
lose public trust Elon I appreciate the
sentiment but you are a couple years too
late it's happening the Federal
indictment by the Biden doj is direct
election interference it is subversion
of the United States election it's just
I don't even know what to say other than
yo look man I don't see how this country
remains on this path I don't see how the
United States stands and continues to
function when you've got the sitting
president filing an indictment against
his chief rival
and the same day and we'll get to in a
minute where evidence is coming out
proving Biden is corrupt and was brought
and was taking bribes